l' alerte a été donnée en tout début
d'après-midi un homme d'une quarantaine
d'années particulièrement agitée
inquiète les autres habitants de cet
immeuble locatif de six appartements les
premiers gendarmes arrivent sur les
lieux procèdent à l'évacuation du
bâtiment et établissent un périmètre de
sécurité
moi j'avais mon fils à l'intérieur donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai on a vite sorti
et enfin voila c'est toujours
impressionnant mais ça fait déjà un
moment qui est voilà qui fait des choses
bizarres donc
donc voilà il menacé avec une bouteille
de gaz de tout faire sauter donc qu'il
fallait un premier précaution qu'il
fallait puis s'éloigner s'éloigner de
tout ça au chaos pendant près de trois
heures un important dispositif de
gendarmes et de pompiers est resté en
place autour de l'immeuble
l'homme retranché a finalement été
interpellé par les gendarmes peu avant
17 rue tout est rentré dans l'ordre
quelques heures les forces de l'ordre
sont intervenus les pompiers l'équipe
médicale tout est rentré dans l'ordre
les personnes vont pouvoir rentrer chez
eux sans souci voilà l'homme a été
conduit à l'hôpital il habitait la
commune depuis plusieurs années